welcome back to las vegas now medicare
star ratings are important to keep in
mind as you find health plans that
benefit and best suit you and we are
breaking it all down with the sponsors
of this segment select health and
joining us today is jennifer vogel thank
you so much jennifer for being here
thank you so much for having us so let's
talk a little bit about select health
and what it is
so select health is a health care
provider we're non-profit we offer
individual plans commercial plans and
also a medicare advantage plan
to clark county and let's talk a little
bit about these five stars in the
ratings and what exactly does that mean
so select health is the first and only
five-star plan currently in
nevada medicare does use about 40
different
specs to kind of determine a five-star
plan and that can include like customer
service your member benefits pharmacy
all kinds of different aspects of the
plan go into the rating and of course
five star being the best one star being
not so great and we're really excited to
be the five star plan this year yeah
congratulations and as people are
exploring plans what should they be
looking out for
i would definitely
review your plan every year i know this
year was a little different but
being five star they do have a chance to
reevaluate their
plans and we're happy to help them with
that um you probably want to go through
like your provider directory make sure
you're still
getting the best
plan that's out there and there's lots
of great plans including our five star
plans so it's a great time to review
what you have and we're happy to help
you with that on selecthealth.org or
give us a call and we'll go through it
and you have a new integration for
your plans and you wanted to touch on
that a little bit so i'll make sure we
get to that we are an integrated health
plan system with intermountain health
care and we are both working together to
provide the healthiest environment for
clark county residents awesome well
thank you so much and again really
quickly just where can people go for
more information and what should they
really be specifically looking for when
they go to the site so a five star is
important of course that's going to give
you the best plan that you can get
you definitely want to go back through
the coverage that you have make sure
you're taking advantage of everything
that's out there for you
there's a lot of great new plans with a
lot of great new benefits so it's a
great time to review and see what you
have and go for all of it well thank you
so much jennifer select health really it
makes it easy for everyone so we
appreciate you being here and thank you
to selecthealth for sponsoring this
segment for more information give them a
call at 1-855-442-9940
or visit selecthealth.org forward slash
medicare las vegas now we'll return
after this break